hi I'm Rob nap by from Wolfram research
and I will be talking about geometry and
meshes which is sort of our geometry
project that sort of unifies typical
mesh computations with symbolic
computation styles you can use that it
actually can be quite efficient in fact
you know using using certain techniques
you can get you can get essentially the
same efficiency as you would get with a
bucket that aesthetic dedicated C
program though you have some advantages
not quite as fast but the development
time is so much smaller that it's it's
much more efficient and I take a really
good example of using some of the
techniques that all you know i'll go
through very briefly today is that the
the finite element most of the finite
element code that Oliver showed in the
previous talk was was written in the
Wolfram language and there's a few bits
that that our dinner special eyes that
we're bottlenecks but most of it is is
written it it's actually done using
automatic automatic compile a
compilation of some of the examples I'll
show you today so um no I'm really bad
with these mouse pads so you may have to
forgive me okay I might need a little
assistant in help here um cuz oh it's
the it's the left okay got it sorry see
ya see I'm hopeless that's okay so so so
this is that this is a this is a this is
the first example and ideas is when you
when you're thinking about doing your
miracle computation with with
Mathematica the Wolfram language it's
it's it's really often good to think
think in terms of bigger bigger things
and I'm going to have a really hard time
with this mouse pad but we'll try in
fact oh man
okay so i'm just going to enter all this
stuff at once because it's going to be a
bit hopeless okay so so I've done is
I've taken a really big data set and and
so my goal in this is to find the idea
is I've got a big big set of random
numbers okay which which just happened
to be uniformly distribute they might
not M ideas I want to find the biggest
the largest difference between any two
consecutive numbers okay so I'm not
sorting it just as they were spit up by
their own generator so basically one way
to do it and this is sort of this is the
way you do it if you're used to fortran
or C for something you'd write a for
loop and this looks almost exactly like
see so I take the part of this the part
of the data I look if the max is bigger
than my current one then I update the
maximum and so on and so forth and that
takes five seconds now if I think
differently and say okay well I want to
find the biggest difference so why don't
I first take the differences and then
look for the maximum of that okay and
that's that's what this code does and
actually this is more expressive in
terms of what i'm trying to do anyway I
mean it's probably easier to read so I
take the differences of my data which
takes consecutive differences if you
look at the documentation they take the
max the absolute values of those and i
get my thing and and it's it's nearly 50
times faster to do it that way and i
think it's totally so i think the lesson
is if you can think instead of doing
little bits of your computation you can
think of doing okay can I work on a big
chunk of data with one or two functions
you're going to always be faster and
we've written a lot of functions so that
they do sort of the inner stuff really
fast and efficiently and then I mean
these are these are not sophisticated
functions differences max ABS those are
simple functions but still using them as
very effective and so but if I do that I
can do this I can actually do a thousand
samples of that and I can get kind of a
rough histogram of what the distribution
looks like we're at safai done it with
that five second one we'd still be
waiting till the end of my talk so
that's um that's one quick example okay
wow this thing is rough um oops I'm at
the wrong way okay so let's look at at
one of the key things to doing stuff
efficiently mathematical and that is
that is this attribute called list able
and a lot of functions have this
attribute and basically what if
something is list of all it means it it
we call threading over list but
basically it does thinks element wise so
this is going to first do the
multiplication so there's no x 1 x 3 + 2
x 4 and then it's going to add 5 & 6 to
it and you can extend to in the
advantage of using these operations in
America is Mathematica if it if all that
list is the same type then mathematic
and ooh optimized operations for example
if these were a really big list of
machine real numbers math America would
actually do the arithmetic and some of
the functions it actually just
automatically does in parallel threads
so so you're getting some sort of you
know sub sub colonel paralyzation there
just for free just by doing our big
operations I mean there's thresholds
which are much bigger than size two
before we try to paralyze but that's the
that's the idea okay so the list of all
the efficiency here is is potentially
enormous so let's make a test a test
thing let's evaluate the sine function
okay that takes no time at all and then
let's try and evaluate doing map over
the sign okay so these are two days it
is as two ways of doing a different
thing and as you see sign is probably
internally paralyzed a little bit i mean
my machine has a well i have no idea
what this machine actually has my
machine has has 4 cores so you can get
quite a speed-up and map actually this
is much more efficient than doing it in
plain Mathematica like that first for
loop because this is another so your
function may be too complicated to do on
a single thing like this ok but what map
does is it actually automatically tries
to compile the function and if you
compile it uses and this is so this is
actually using a mathematical Pilar but
there's some little overhead time in you
know doing the compilation that's pretty
small
and then it's just not as streamlined as
the plane function so when you can do a
big thing at once do it if not map or
sometimes table can be efficient ways to
do it because those are Auto compiled
okay so let's get up here sorry for
being so awkward with this okay so other
ways you can use list ability there's a
couple i can do this now i'm going to
get this started because this takes a
while then i'll talk about the other
option and this this is a this gives you
see sorry for struggling okay so well so
this one takes a long time so you can
you can actually give the function the
list of all attributes so that will do
it will do that automatically and
there's two ways you can give a function
the list of a trapeze you can use a use
a definition with patterns which which
are you know the down values for the
function ok and then battle list over it
or you can actually define a an explicit
function now the advantage the advantage
of this is that the upper thing is it's
much more flexible but the advantage of
this one is because the function is
there and everything is explicit in it
we actually auto compile this case as
well we can't really auto compile that
though there's potential in the future
we'll be able to do that and we're
working on the technology but this is
Otto compile and you can see it makes a
big difference in the amount of speed
for doing the same thing so often if you
can do things that way that's that's
quite effective ok so um on to the next
ok so another way to do it is you can
actually um and this is this is this I
think is a really powerful feature you
can compile a function and this is using
our compile now a lot of things are Auto
compiled so you don't necessarily need
to compile everything but if you have a
thing in your code that you know it's
going to be run a lot of times it's
often worth compiling it ok using our
compile command and it's pretty it's
pretty flexible it has a limited number
of native types but within those
of types you can do a lot of different
operations in Mathematica and so I get
you know even more speed out of doing it
doing it this way and the the runtime
attributes goes to list able says that
this is a faculty going to act like a
list of all function so on the arguments
had a list over the argument so it
actually applies so we're actually
applying the compile function on each
individual thing there so that's a
really effective way to do it and I'll
she'll be showing it a bit you can
actually compile using compile for a lot
of cases you can compile the C code and
you get even more efficiency that way so
as an example of that I'll show so
here's it here's a fun example so and
this is something I do a lot and and
actually this is kind of what we do this
is showing you a little bit what we do
in our in our internal functions though
we do it in a in a different way in a
more robust way so what I'm doing is I'm
writing at a function here called
iterator compile and I give it a
function and I'm asking it to be an
explicit function in this case the first
case and some options okay and it's
going to assume that function takes you
know two parameters so it's going to be
a map function like R and X and what I'm
kind of thinking of is logistic map so
it will compile that and then it will
run through and zero iterations to sort
of let transients die out and then it'll
look at what it puts the rest of the
iterations into bins so you can see
where the where the function values tend
to go and so to see this you can give it
any function that it should map the
intervals to a cell for you're going to
have it blow up but that's something you
can give any function to so let's see if
it let's try it with a logistic map ok
so there's logistic ok that worked and
then we can actually do a plot of this
oops oh I didn't get that properly
evaluated did I ok let's try this again
okay and that's what that's what this
been this happens to be a value where it
sort of done the the period doubling
bifurcation Zand stuff and so you can't
if I chose a value with a smaller r
which i don't have time to do you can
actually see so here's a function that
actually puts that together and it makes
a bifurcation diagram out of that and I
think these actually look pretty nice oh
no oh boy oh boy okay well okay so I
wanted to show you how I can compile
this to see to make it faster now this
this this computer apparently doesn't
have a/c compiler which seems to me like
a horrible sin but ok whatever but yeah
it can't find it may well have a/c
compiler but so but in any case and if
you don't have one in your system you
get this you can actually install a
visual studio express for free so it's
not so hard to do but it actually makes
a nice i'm not to show you the whole
thing but it makes a nice looking
bifurcation diagram and even with this
without the see it did it you know
pretty interactive speed and with the
see it's even faster so so that's kind
of that that example and it's you know
worth seeing how how that works ok i
still have a little time so that's so
there's sort of two parts in my lesson
today one is that you know by by
thinking about big things and compiling
things and even compiling things to see
and even in cases where you can't quite
figure out how to get Mathematica do it
we have a thing called library function
that allows you to write a little module
and see that might do the critical part
of computation and that connects
directly and with the compiler so now
i'm going to say okay so so sometimes
you want to compile and then the other
half the story is well sometimes you
don't ok so so and and the point is that
if you're doing a particular calculation
like i was doing here say a bifurcation
diagram it's great you wanting you know
you're just working with numbers not
doing but here mathematica has a lot of
functions that work with functions and
by Mathematica have the symbolic form
it's able to do so much more than a
typical numerical
so let's take this example okay and I
think this is a really nice picture
former colleague put together is so this
is so Mathematica when we give this to
say we're going to compute this integral
numerically when we give it to
Mathematica it sees it very clearly it
actually sees the whole structure
symbolically the problem it can do some
symbolic analysis and decide okay this
is the right method to use here this has
discontinuity so I'll break the
discontinuity points where it's a
typical numerical method it's all fuzzy
you know all you can do is all you can
do a sample okay so um so I'm going to
go in the interest of time let's see I
need to go down here okay so and i'll
just show you i think this is kind of
interesting so what i'm doing here and
this is another thing you can do with
the compiler that's not a default so
here I've said runtime options evaluate
symbolically goes to false and so
sometimes you want to compile function
as sort of an object well the default is
it will try and evaluate symbolically
which is not in this case so useful so
here I can actually give it a symbolic
acts it leaves it unavail you ate until
X's numerical which is really there's a
little known but very convenient option
of our compiler which I kind of wanted
to show okay now let's do the integral
with this okay and so I'm getting all
sorts of messages it's done a bunch of
by sections and all these recursive by
sections are done right near the
discontinuity points and also because
that integral is extremely Scylla tori
so it's not it's not getting the
conversion to expect and so just
remember that took point seven seconds
ok now let's go up and I actually if you
look at the notebook later I have some
analysis and how you can see you could
actually see where Mathematica actually
sampled the function I'm going to skip
that in the interest of time so let's
look at how Mathematica does this ok so
Mathematica recognizes the discontinuity
so it has breaks it up into three piece
wise functions and integral just some so
it does three separate integrals really
ok and then it can it can sort of you
know it does appoint an approximation of
this and it uses special rule
balls Priscilla Tori functions that get
very good approximation very quickly
okay so it's actually using the symbolic
form to do something here and and let's
do this integral again okay now the
first time two point seven two seconds
that's not quite fair because if we do
it again we get point 04 seconds the
reason that first time took point seven
two seconds is well mathematic has to
load the packages which do the symbolic
analysis so the first time you doing
here to go like that it might be slow
but the next time it's going to be super
fast and this is a lot faster than the
the other version and it turns out I
won't show you but if you if you look at
the computation in the notebook this is
accurate to 10 to the minus 14 and the
other error has example about point 0 0
0 1 so 10 to the minus fourth so it's
you know eight orders of magnitude
better done faster and that's what
that's what the symbolic analysis can do
can do for us and oh gosh are not
actually doing better than I thought so
so I'm going to go through some of the
symbolic analyses we do then I have one
final example there's time so so some of
the sim this is this is not an
exhaustive list but this is a this is a
fairly you know representative list of
the sort of things we do so so one
that's really important is like an nd
solve we we we identify sparse structure
for evaluation and that's that's key for
actually save so when we say computer
Jacobian numerically as opposed to
analytically by using the spar structure
used able to use far far fewer L
evaluations and that can be huge in some
problems okay and so so we use that also
just doing the sparse sparse linear
algebra is much faster and that's
absolutely essential to like this finite
element stuff but we often you know we
sort of integrated sparse structure
computer from symbolic formula and
sparse structure from what we just know
the the assemble the symbol matrix is
like a finite element so so it's all
sort of all all integrated we do were
able to do index reduction for
differential algebraic
equations automatically okay so so if
you have a higher index problem we can
try and analyze that and you know figure
out figure out what the real index is
due in dec reduction and solve the
reduced system so it's you know without
a higher index over we're able to get
fairly efficient solutions I mean
another good example is discrimination
of pde so Oliver showed you these PDS we
can discretize and when we get to the
nonlinear stuff being able to analyze
the PDE for the right structure it's
going to be essential to have the the
symbolic stuff there again another thing
we do is heuristic identification of
methods based on bright and I think that
integrate example was good we chose for
part of it it was slowly varying so we
just chose an ordinary method for part
of it was quickly veraleen so we chose
an axillary method detection of
discontinuities we do that in ND solve
and integrate a bunch of other functions
and again we can often simplify the
problem bio transformations so there's
just some of the really important ones
but there are there are quite a few okay
so I've got I'm being told I'm getting
close to the time so let me just show
you this example I think it's it's
another representative example which I
think makes a really nice picture and
we'll just finish with this picture if I
can get the thing to move me and there
we go
they're okay so so this is this is a
neat I think this is a fun example okay
so so I've got a guy I didn't show the
de very quickly but I'll kind of explain
what's happening here is the D actually
had to two different discontinuity
surfaces one is on the surface of this
ball and the other is on this point and
so what happens is ND solve i just gave
it as equations actually the
discontinuities appear as the sine
function in there so Wendy solve starts
from its initial condition it integrates
along until it hits that first
discontinuity now there's continuity as
I chose so that actually they the vector
field points inward towards the ball on
either side if you try that one or any
method what's going to happen is it's
going to choke it's going to say which
side do i go on i can't go on either
side i'm stuck and sometimes they'll
oscillate and chatter and sometimes
they'll just get stuck in this case it
actually just gets stuck in 3d but ND
solve computes the discontinuity it
basically sums the vector fields to use
a so called sliding mode solution it
does that then it's another
discontinuity this one actually slides
on the interface between the plane as
you see farther up it escapes from the
ball and continues on the plane and
that's something without the symbolic
analysis unless you wrote the particular
to duel to it you'd never get the
solution to and so I think that's what's
in with that example and we can go to
questions